genetically modified organisms are back
in the news as EU environment ministers
meet in Brussels to debate the
possibility for member states to
restrict or even prohibit their
cultivation this could apply in all or
part of the territory to GMOs that have
been authorized at EU level for reasons
other than health and environmental
considerations while they're widely
grown in the Americas and Asia
genetically modified crops are generally
unpopular in Europe where public
opposition is strong and
environmentalist to raise concerns about
the impact on biodiversity ministers
will also discuss the new framework for
climate and energy policy for 2030 the
main elements are a reduction in
greenhouse gas emissions by forty
percent below the 1990 level and an
eu-wide binding target for renewable
energy of at least twenty seven percent
energy efficiency is a key component of
the 2030 framework and a review of the
energy efficiency directive is expected
to be concluded later this year
ministers will also hold a debate on the
annual growth survey notably on how to
improve the uptake of green economy
priorities into the national reform
programmes of member states and in the
overall semester cycle